mais quelqu'un car deux mois cette
couronne et fait attention c'est un
modèle vient bien tu as vraiment cru
pouvoir temps fuit m'enfuir mais non non
non ce venir justement grand défi de ton
déguisement si ingénieux
l'ordinateur a reconnu comme étant le
fugitif bouffe abandonné pari que fait
ta bêtise mais j'ai beaucoup de bêtises
avant celle-là je n'ai jamais où
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup et alité
beaucoup de bêtises avant celle là ton
je dois devrait toujours téva c'est
pourquoi nous assurer qu'il ne fera plus
jamais de bêtises mais je n'en ferait
plus mais tu pourrais je n'en ferais
plus mais tu pourrais je n'en périple on
peut continuer comme ça longtemps on
continue on ne pourrait plus et tu
pourras fait danser répulsion à torse
mais je devrais blé